Virgen talk about cryptanalysis of non
lattice based games for the most part
and I feel like this I mean there's a
lot of post quantum crypto fans in here
right people who want to advocate for
like lotta space crypto everywhere and
so there's like two approaches right you
can wait for the physicists to like
build a quantum computer or you can
proactively take out the competition
like classically so lattices are a
useful tool for this so you'll have a
few things in your toolbox maybe
hopefully there's a lot of boring copy
computations in this talk so basically
we're gonna do like a super way too fast
survey of like a bunch of different
techniques and a lot of these are like
super ad hoc and I'm gonna be waving my
hands like incredibly vigorously through
the whole talk so I apologize for the
people who are rigorous and but maybe I
mean there's some good techniques in
here that like don't always seem to get
translated so maybe there will be
something useful otherwise it's fun to
break things so we're gonna break things
so our warmup number one will be
knapsacks because this is the beginning
of a lot of space script analysis so the
sort of idea behind a knapsack and the
hope behind sort of building knapsack
cryptography was that knapsack it should
be a np-hard problem so we have a bunch
of integers a1 through a and and some
target integer and you want to find a
subset of those elements that sum up to
your target integer so you know you
could write this as like finding a
solution to all of you legs the eyes are
0 1 you want to find a set of them that
satisfies this ok
canonical np-hard problem so the attack
outlined by ligurius analytic oh and
there's like a bunch of different
versions of this the simplest version is
the knapsack lattice basis so these are
row vectors right and so if you find
some subset of these rows that zeroes
out this last coordinate then you get
like a 1 in all of these locations and
this should be kind of like a small
vector and in fact like you
then in in length and so if these AIS
are not too large or not too small and
they're like chosen randomly according
to some useful distribution then you can
use some dead to the argument to show
that this desired vector is likely the
shortest vector and then you can hope
that some lattice reduction algorithm
will find it so there are a few things
that you can do to soup this up because
it doesn't work super well in practice
when you actually try to run it you can
do things like put weights on the
diagonal to try to sort of force these
the eyes to be small rather than sort of
arbitrary integers that the lattice
reduction algorithm happens to like in
the 1980s we've heard this a couple of
times when the original papers are
written they sort of stop to it we hope
that lol will find the shortest vector
because they were running it on super
tiny instances where lll did find the
shortest vector in practice of course
more advanced versions of this are kind
of like the lattice paste crypto that
we're using now so so but this is sort
of not true anymore but obviously there
are sort of a lot of well for small
lattices this this does work and this is
a very common shape of lattice the basis
that we see a lot so we heard a lot
about lattice algorithms in practice in
the last talk
so just for like super concrete terms
I'm mostly gonna be talking about using
lll so there's like kind of two things
that we care about in practice and I
care about concrete computations so
martin said he didn't care about
concrete computations and you wanted you
to set parameters i care about actually
running concrete computations so the the
things that we care about for concrete
computations one is empirically if you
choose like a random lattice and you run
lll on it you get a much better
approximation factor than the provable
guarantee you get like a 1.0 two
dimension is your approximation factor
and this works pretty well for for kind
of cryptographically generated lattices
the other thing that's relevant is what
size of lattice can you actually run
beyond the fact that it's like
polynomial time so kind of the best
numbers that I've seen this is a paper
that was posted on preprint archive last
month so dimension 4096 with 6000 bit
integers in four days as far as I know
they have not released their
implementation this is paralyzed so it's
like it's a new technique but roughly
kind of a few thousand dimensions ish is
like what is it the limit of what people
are actually concretely able to you can
precisely define random if you want or
you can wave your hands and also like
not precisely define it so empirically I
mean this is this is a this is not this
is an empiric result this is
experimental it's not proven if somebody
could prove this would be awesome but as
far as I can as far as I know I should
have put that as an open question
actually is say something rigorous about
this stuff about sand piles yeah
empirically what you can do is you can
generate like a random lattice that
looks like this and run lll on it and
what you find is one point like an
approximation factor so here are six
dozen big numbers in bit numbers means
like a subset sum with the modulus which
is six thousand bits
I don't remember what kind of lattices
they were generating but yeah a knapsack
lattice with what 6,000 bit integers
should be relatively to take a square
matrix where all the then that element
would be even bigger than that oh I
don't remember if it was determinate or
whether it was something else so they
could look that up now and so yeah we
heard a lot about bkz and enumeration in
the last talk also so I just grabbed
like the like largest result that I
could find from lattice challenge out
org and they were doing 250 dimensional
bkz and pruning so that's somewhere
where we're at in terms of like like
approaching exact shortest vectors if
you actually want to run this stuff the
implementation to use is FP LLL where
many of the authors are in this room
that's the sort of the practical note
okay so back to our knapsack problem so
we are asking for kind of a short
integer solution to like a linear
equation and I just want to note that
finding an integer solution is trivial
right like if these elements has like
GCD one then you can just like use the
extended Euclidean algorithm to find
some integers satisfying this and then
you can just like multiply by your
target and that gives you an integer
solution so that's trivial and if you're
not careful in setting up your lattice
reduction problems often lol will be
super helpful and like find solutions
that look like this for you so it's like
one of the dark arts of like doing all
the script analysis stuff is setting up
the problem so that it does something it
does what you want and not the easy
thing this is totally not a precise okay
so that's all I'm gonna say about
knapsacks our warmup
number two is going to be and true so we
already saw it and true at least once
I'm in the past couple of days
so just like super quickly okay so we
have our ring we're working like an
integer like polynomials with
coefficients mod Q mod X to the n plus 1
and then we take two just like small
polynomials in the sense of the
coefficients are in negative 1 0 or 1
like kind of I think equally distributed
between them and so we take two random
randomly generated polynomials of that
form in this ring and then the public
key is G F inverse value computed over
this ring and then the entry problem
among the other things that you might
want to do is given the public key like
how hard is it to compute the and so the
coppersmith and Shamir attack looks like
follows so if you have this h i was
going to write this out but it was like
too big so if you make this like
circulant matrix we've already seen this
all times that represents multiplication
by H then this has the property that if
you multiply like the vector that
corresponds to the coefficients of F
times this matrix mod Q then that's
equal to the G value and so if you set
up this kind of 2n by 2n matrix where
you have the identity in one block and Q
times the identity and in this block and
then this multiplication by H matrix in
this block then this vector that is the
solution that's like F and G is a vector
in this lattice so you see you see if
you like multiply I'm I'm doing row
vectors so if you like take here if you
multiply like F then that ends up
multiplying by here and so you get like
the coefficients of F and then here you
can have some other garbage that's like
reduction mod Q and that gives you the
coefficients of G so that's the insight
behind the coppersmith and Shamir attack
against and true so the way around this
is to make it so that this is really too
large to solve set up your parameters so
that you don't find actually the
inspector then there's a set of back and
forth there's a number of authors in
this room who've written paper is unlike
variants of this where you exploit parts
of the algebraic structure of this
lattice so the reason I showed this is
sort of I think both the knapsacks and
the N true problem sort of set up the
main idea of what we're gonna be doing
here which is that many Kerch analysis
problems can be formulated either as you
want to find some small solution to some
polynomial or system of equations
subject to some strength constraints or
you want to find a polynomial with small
coefficients and sometimes these are
equivalent like or you can actually
formulate them as like dual problems
that if you find a polynomial small
coefficients it has a small solution or
if you find a pause
in the right way so this picture of like
the framework that we're gonna put a lot
of these problems in so we've seen this
a number of times in a bunch of the
lectures already so I just want to sort
of mention because this is going to come
up a lot in our concrete representations
so if we have some polynomial then we
can embed it in a lattice in sort of
multi or we can represent it as a
lattice vector in a couple of different
ways we can represent it as a sequence
of coefficients or we can represent it
as like evaluating it at different
points and both of these are homomorphic
under additions so the lattice will
preserve like the additive structure of
like you can add two polynomials
together and you get another polynomial
what the lattices are gonna be
introducing a new geometric structure
that doesn't exist in a lot of the crypt
analysis problems like a priori so like
we have these algebraic problems of like
find some polynomial that you multiply
it by like the universe of another
polynomial and you get the solution that
has no geometric structure but once you
put it into a lattice suddenly there is
like a geometric structure and we try to
exploit that somehow to find our
solution but like one of the things that
you end up fighting with is that the
geometric guarantees like don't map
exactly on to the solution that we want
and so we're trying to like use this
these lattice algorithms as like a black
box to get what we want it's like weird
to talk about like the l2 norm of a
polynomial like do some funky things to
get around that but somehow we don't
know how to talk about like the right
norms for polynomials okay so I guess
that's kind of like the intro now we're
gonna move on to like at least my
favorite theorem your favorite so I'll
spend a while talking about coppers most
method so I'll start with the theorem
statement so Carson's method says that
given some polynomial f of degree D
and some integer modulus and we want to
find all of the integer roots that are
small they satisfy something bound and
that our 0 mod n this is okay this is
fine I don't know why is this actually
interesting so for one a general method
to solve like find solutions to two
polynomials mod n would actually just
break our singing out right because the
RSA problem is precisely if you have
some site like RSA encrypted cipher text
you want to find that mod n and that is
your encrypted message so we believe
that this problem is hard in general
without the size content constraint
solution if we believe that RSA
encryption is secure
so but of course for some kinds of end
we can solve this problem efficiently so
if n is prime then you can find roots of
polynomials mod primes efficiently and
if we know the factorization of n then
we can totally solve mod H prime and
then like use Chinese remainder theorem
pencil lifting to basically get a
solution mod n so the thing is
interesting about coppersmiths theorem
is that we can find these solutions
without actually factoring it so we gave
up a little bit we can only find small
solutions but we can find small
solutions no matter what if you can say
I have an example of this so certainly
like if we if we eliminate that so if if
you well if you're looking for small if
there's a small solution here like
without the modern part then you can
totally compute that because that's over
the integers so that's what what covers
nospherus
it's boring so this is so coppersmith
theorem is interesting only for like
other kinds of polynomials if X is if
your solution is is less than n to the 1
over e then you just have a solution
over the integers and that's kind of why
the theorem works
this is totally doable so in this
example tells us that like this theorem
is working sort of when we expect it to
so for this it's boring but if we
started adding like extra monomials in
here you can factor the quadratic in the
zucchini argue this way that
approximates the lattice problems for
approximation of factors so for which
the problem is not MBR de are still at
least as hard as factoring to provide
some kind of harness that's what I was
trying to do and then he managed it to
prevent P harness which point the
question of whether you could reduce
factoring - laughs - this became a
theoretical less interesting he was
using the exact version of
love dis problems method doesn't care
about the approximation factor yeah I
mean there are other versions that an
open question
Daniela's open questions so okay I will
I will try to go over the proof of
coppersmiths theorem so we'll see how
this works so we're gonna input our
polynomial F so it's some degree D
whatever integer coefficients and our
integer modulus and and we want to find
all small roots our mod N and we have
this bound capital R on the size of the
root that we're looking for so the way
that this algorithm works is its it
works by constructing this auxiliary
polynomial so that any root solution
here is a root over the integers and
then we can just find we can just factor
this polynomial and find its integer
roots and then output the ones that do
so that is our general program that
we're going to try to do okay so this
has kind of two steps one is like how do
we how do we ensure this so first we can
ensure that any polynomial that is
constructed by the algorithm is if we
evaluated at our root solution here it's
zero mod N and we do that by
construction and we do that by
constructing it from essentially our
inputs so we know that at the bar is
your o'madden 10 because it is a root
mod n we also know that n is 0 mod n so
any like any for example integer linear
combination of these 2 is also 0 mod n
but also any polynomial combination of
these 2 is 0 mod n so we're gonna take
polynomial like integer polynomial
combinations of these two
we're gonna try to construct auxiliar
polynomial from these two things so that
ensures as long as we know that we have
the structure then q evaluated our route
is gonna be zero mana so this property
number one property number two is making
sure that our exhilarate all anomie all
would we evaluate it at our solution
this is our solution
it's strictly less than n that we're
gonna try to do by like sort of stupid
bounds like if we just sort of bound the
evaluation of our polynomial with
absolute values then if you sum all
these up and if this is less than n then
we're good so once you have these two
properties then something that is zero
mod N and strictly less and then the
only proper possible value that that is
is zero so now we know that Q of R is
actually identically zero and so then
it's R as a root over the integers and
we can just find it efficiently good
with our program so far okay so concrete
example of this if we limited ourselves
to auxilary polynomials of degree three
to be super concrete it looks something
like this
the only multiple of X or of f that has
degree 3 is the integer multiple of that
then we can take some powers of ant-like
powers of x times n that's cool and then
some integer coefficients we wrote them
out like this then we get the
coefficients of our and I mean super
literal about this because what we're
actually going to do it's like just look
at the coefficient embedding of this as
a lot of spaces and so we can write down
this simple looking lattice spaces and
then we know that the coefficient vector
of our desired polynomial is a vector in
this lattice we're not quite there yet
because I said we wanted to bound like
this value so the easy way to do this is
to just kind of like add these extra
scaling coefficients like in to our
lattice and then that means the l1 norm
of any
coefficient or any vector in this
lattice happens to like kind of match
exactly this value that we want to bound
so this is strictly less than n then
we're done so now we're looking for a
relatively short vector in this concrete
lattice that we constructed how do we do
that we run LLO on it so this is kind of
a summary of what we did so far okay so
we're gonna construct the lattice of the
scaled coefficient betting embedding of
some suitably chosen polynomials we're
gonna find a short vector in the in the
lattice so if we use lll then we know
that we want okay so we have the l1 norm
of the vector we can found that using
the l2 norm then we can found the l2
norm I'm going to drop the square root
of n here by the pound that we get from
LOL and if this is strictly less than n
then we know that this is strictly less
than n and then we're done so the only
thing that we need to verify now is like
this quantity here the calculations
later on but basically what you do is
you just construct lattices check the
determinant found and when if the
determinant found says that this applies
then you're good so actually achieving
the coppersmith bound of like and to the
1 over d is a little bit annoying
there's there's an optimization problem
that I don't want to show you the way
that you get that is there's two extra
things one of them is instead of taking
just like say single powers of these
values if you take higher higher
multiplicities like powers of F and
powers of n then you need that to
achieve the theorem the other thing you
can do is increase the total degree of
the auxiliary polynomial that you're
willing to do and the degree of the
auxiliary polynomial is exactly the
dimension of the lattice that you're
reducing it also tells you a bound on
the number of possible solutions that
you can get so these two things plus
being clever about which of the
polynomials because you can generate
like a large number of polynomials that
satisfy this that you want to take a
linear combination of them and you're
clever about which ones you actually
like include in your lattice basis that
you're going to reduce
so that is the kind of whole set of sort
of tricks that coppers miss veeram
exploits
yeah it gives you um it gives you a
lesser button so I think this this gives
you and to the one-sixth like with a
with a 4x4 lattice and I mean you can
you can just like write stuff down and
like if you care about things that are
much less than n to the 1 over d you can
usually solve it with much smaller
lattices there is nothing here at stake
here so yeah that's a good point so
there's nothing heuristic here and the
exponential approximation factor of lol
turns into a constant factor loss in the
size of the root that you can find so
the 2 to the 2 to the M turns into a
like n over 1/2 to the 1 over D and you
can get rid of that just by like that's
pretty cool like this is this is one of
those like rare examples of like lattice
crypt analysis that is like totally
rigorous and like doesn't care about the
approximation factor of lol just like
magical
it's a there's a half I think is n to
the 1 over T divided by 2 because when
you look at the term you have a 2 to the
N number 4 and then you have the
determinant of these so when you're when
you're actually constructing this thing
you end up the dimension of the lattice
is going to be a polynomial and in like
D putting like the two to the N like
into the other so this is your balance
isn't here I don't know I feel like
maybe there's a cleaner way to explain
it but like if you like write down the
determinant of this thing like in
general in terms of like the degree in
multiplicity and then you like solved
for what the optimum value is just like
fold the approximation factor in
I wonder Bridget mentioned briefly a
result that I have with Ted chin Berg
and Zack Sheeran and Brett Hemingway
which the question is whether this is
optimal and this is optimal in the sense
that if you have any method trying to
solve this problem that constructs an
auxiliary polynomial that preserves the
algebraic roots of your input polynomial
then you can't improve this bount there
may be improvements that like don't
preserve all the algebraic roots but
yeah so so it may be it's it's certainly
the case that there exist polynomials
that yeah they have like exponential
roots like so an example is is like you
know solving some polynomial mod like a
big power of two so like once you get
just beyond the yeah and there are
polynomials where like for example like
the RSA problem where we know that
there's a unique solution and like even
if we had a promise of there being a
unique solution that it find any from
2011 so you can write down let's see
actually so there is an exact
correspondence between the how grave
gram partial factoring or factoring with
partial knowledge or like this single
variable approximate GCD problem and the
Reed Solomon List decoding I'll talk
about the factoring of partial knowledge
basically if you restate the factoring
up with partial knowledge problem over
the ring of polynomials rather than and
you use polynomial a lot of spaces of
reduction then you get exactly
reed-solomon lista coding stuff
yeah you can you can do coppersmiths
method for other rings so in this in
this paper we we also wrote down in
addition to writing the down coppersmith
method for polynomial rings we wrote it
down for like ideal like rings of a
number over number fields and it gets
really disgusting right because like the
natural way to do it I was gonna talk
about this a little bit the natural way
to do this is to like have every integer
here be like the canonical embedding
like a block wise matrix and then you
get this horrible gigantic lattice you
can do it but then the dimension of the
lattice blows up so much that it seems
hardly worth doing but maybe there's
something here I don't know because the
amplification method that coppersmith
has by taking like extra powers of
things does I mean it gives you a
non-trivial result in there okay open
problem can you say anything else about
this like coppersmith it seemed we seem
to have a pretty exact like
impossibility result but like this is
weak in some sense so it would be nice
to say something got RSA but like that
would be proving that RSA is actually
hard so maybe you can't the other thing
is that the notion of black magic has
come up multiple times so one of the
black magic things is like how do you
know which polynomials you include in
your bases and like I don't know how to
do this I just played with them and like
figured it out and this is what
everybody who does this does so I don't
have like a systematic description of
like what you do
um okay we're gonna do some applications
because I'm secretly like a practical
person who likes snuck in to this
somehow so just make sure I mean we
mentioned our site before but just make
sure everybody's like on the same page
about our essay like we have our public
module is PQ we shouldn't be able to
factor this that would be bad
we have an encryption exponent everybody
uses small ones in practice so we can
just say e small then our decryption
exponent is a inverse mod via then
and then we encrypt by like raising our
message to the e we're gonna be doing a
bunch of examples about breaking RSA so
let's start with this one we already saw
this one so this should be easy okay so
we have this is sage code so I have my
message and I want to just encode it
like I just did a super lazy and adjourn
coding is like to get numbers and
integers and then I have 1024 bit RSA so
every 10 20 probe modulus and then I do
textbook RSA message cubed lot in
problem here because missing one
just to the right so A through Z plus
one through nine
yeah there's a problem the mod n is not
doing anything because like this is this
is not anywhere near like 1024 bits if I
just like take the integer cube root of
my ciphertext and I totally get my
plaintext back so so I'll use padding
right I like giving this to undergrads
okay
here's another example so I made a
smaller modulus that's just so it will
fit on the page so that's not the
insecure part you know I have my message
which is the password for today's
swordfish and I encoded it's an integer
the same way and I encrypt it using
textbook RSA with and I just want to
make sure that okay so it is not the
case that we don't wrap around so I mean
my module is small enough so that like
this wraps around so we don't have that
problem but like maybe if somebody
happens to know that like the message
has this like fixed formatting like the
password for today is and then the
message then so okay so our adversary
starts by like writing down some value
that's like the the padding for the
message that they can guess so the
password for today is and then some
guess for like the length of the
password and they make some value this
is just a placeholder this is like our
upper bound on the size of the password
that we're gonna try to find then we
construct exactly this this lattice that
I constructed before so it's a four by
four lattice and we have some like
powers of n here and then we have the
coefficients of our thanks to the e -
capital X is just this this bound on the
size of the root that we're looking for
this was what was our
you know where's oh this one oh yeah I
should have yeah I guess I guess 99 nano
movie if I shouldn't use easy this is
easy so here's my here's my Gladys paces
now I run LLO on it and I take the first
vector and I take I construct this
polynomial from the coefficients of my
first vector and I'm like read rescaling
as necessary and then I compute the
roots and there is one root of my
polynomial over the integers and it is
exactly the solution so this totally
works
right
another I feel like in a room full of
Harris it's like important to show that
like things actually like can be
computed okay so here is the question
that Kris was raising of kind of finding
solutions modular divisors so this is
just like the coppersmith version but
instead of so we have some polynomial
and we have some integer n but instead
of finding solutions mod and we want to
find solutions modded divisor B of n so
like sum we want to find all the roots
such that like f of R 0 mod B for B
divides N and B is larger than like some
value and then we can find these roots
when it's less than and to the beta
squared over the degree yeah with that
this will give you a once you have R
then you can compute the GCD is not an
input so this is the statement that like
if we're given an N we don't know the
factorization of n but if there exists
any roots mod any divisor of n then it
will find it and then then we can
compute the divisors and the proof is
basically the same as coppersmiths
univariate method so what I just showed
you instead of finding a lattice vector
that's like less than n we're looking
for a lattice vector that's like less
than
so the reed-solomon list decoding
problem you state this theorem odd
polynomials and then your n is going to
be the product of like X minus like all
of your evaluation points visor is going
to tell you which about you the correct
locations
so one super interesting application of
this theorem is factoring with partial
partial knowledge so if you were given
half of the bit say the most release we
cut in half of the bits of one of the
factors P of an RSA modulus P times Q
then you can factor the modulus in
polynomial time so the proof is super
simple so like if if we had this value
I'm using like the mathematical version
of so a is like the most innate in half
of the bits of a factor P and like it's
also multiplied by some power of two so
like there's some value where like a
plus R is equal to P where R is small
and a is some value that we know then we
can construct our polynomial X plus a
and we know that F of R is 0 mod p and
say P is the larger of the two factors
so it's bounded by n to the one half so
we're applying the theorem before with
degree D equals 1 and beta equals 1/2
and so this should be able to find roots
that are less than n to the beta squared
over D which is n to the 1/4 which is
exactly half
ah no mealtime and this is also not
heuristic if they're if for the bounds
that you put into the problem there
exists effect
so it'll find all routes such that if
there exists route mod some factor then
all output by the way this gives you a
bound on the number of possible values
that satisfy this other questions yeah
so this will give you everything that
satisfies the problem so just to like
prove to you that this works I'll do the
concrete example so we have P and Q or
512 bits and we have our RSA modulus P
times Q and then I have my value a I'm
gonna erase the 86 Lisa t-paint bits of
P so if I write it out I've erased the
86 Lisa this information I'm gonna do
this with a three-dimensional lattice so
I define some bound just like some power
of two to the 86 is bigger than 86 bits
that I deleted I construct a three
dimensional lattice
I run LLL construct a polynomial and
then a plus the root is equal to P
I think there was only one route yeah
it's a corner economy oh yeah there
isn't there some other so if you think
that reed-solomon list decoding is
optimal and this beta squared gives you
exactly the bound for reed-solomon less
decoding so I think there's some proof
that ballistic coding pout is optimal
but of course for the case where say n
does not have a lot of factors then you
then that wouldn't apply and so then
there would be cases where you would
have with Ted converging and Zack share
and read Hemingway we looked at this and
trying to prove like a similar kind of
bound as for the coppersmith case with
auxiliary polynomials produces like it
requires new theory that Ted doesn't
know how to do so that is an open
problem is like having some having some
bound here
let me just get this calculation because
important this was just like how to do
the the determinant bound so there's a
bunch of kind of other kinds of RSA
attacks if you care about practice like
so factoring the bits of P quarter the
bits of D half the bits of D mod P minus
1 these are all like in the same
framework so I move on to another
example so this is small RSA D so I've
constructed my RSA modulus same as
before and it says P times Q D I made a
little bit less than 1/4 of the bits of
n so it's 254 bits which should be like
cryptographically number and I can start
to eat as I was supposed to so eat D is
small but it's not that small and here I
do some black magic again I construct a
3x3 lattice I run lll on it and it turns
out that like DS actually just spat out
in one of the coordinates all the attack
so this is the lattice based version of
a theorem of wiener so basically you can
officially compute D when T is less than
n to the load turn then to the 1/4 he
did it using continued fractions but you
could also do it with the and the way
this works you can write this actually
as kind of in the same framework as
we've been talking about so we have this
RSA equation which is e and D are
inverses mod T right and we can make
this into an integer equation by
introducing an integer multiple K here
so now we have like so we have this like
integer equation in some unknowns we
don't we know e we don't know D we don't
know K we do know n we know one we don't
know P and Q but we do know one so
there's some values we know and so if we
let s say equals P times Q in computing
P times P plus or P plus Q is like
enough to factor n that we can rewrite
this I put all the values that we don't
know in red we do know some phones
on them so we have like kind of this
integer like multivariate equation with
some unknowns that are we have bounds on
that we would like to solve for so we
can rewrite this and so if we we
basically have two variables here you
would like to we have an equation that
looks like this and we would like to
find a solution
and essentially what I'm doing is a
variation of the same technique bounds
on the size of the looking for I
construct a lattice basis that
corresponds to the coefficients of some
cleverly chosen polynomials that happen
to satisfy the solution that I'm looking
for and the lattice reduction is
actually finding this equation so I'm
just pulling out
I want to I can like computes like so
this is I mean I'm putting this in like
the bivariate coppersmith framework but
it doesn't actually require that so this
result is is outright provable it's not
it's not here at all
but I'm putting it in that framework
just kiss you should be able to do this
with a two-by-two lattice but it's like
a little bit more okay so but I do want
to mention that there's this theorem of
Bonet and Durfee they improve this bound
a little bit by basically taking the
same equation and like applying the
coppersmith techniques of like higher
multiplicity and degree so they were
able to improve the bound to end to the
point 292 which is kind of a and so
essentially they're clever about their
choice of sub lattice and they're using
higher multiple seasoned degree the
conjecture that their method can be
improved to the end to the point 5 but
like
it's difficult situation somewhere else
yeah they have it in their paper I
forget exactly what it is I thought it
was like point five minus something in
their paper but I don't remember or
maybe maybe so in general okay so we
just sort of like try to extract the
sort of expand our techniques from like
univariate polynomials to like
multivariate polynomials possibly
systems with polynomials and so your
input would be like some multivariate
polynomials or some like maybe some
system of polynomials and you want to
output a bunch of integers such that
like your polynomial vanishes mod n and
you can kind of do the same thing but
it's like suddenly much less rigorous
and you can't prove anything and it's
like totally black art and everybody
just does ad hoc things so what you want
to do is essentially like find a
collection of like you construct the
same kind of lattice and do the same
kinds of bounds checking and you want to
find a bunch of short vectors in your
lattice that correspond to a system of
multivariate polynomials and dump them
into like a solver and have it spit out
the there's a bunch of issues one okay
so you have to find a bunch of short
equations you have to or short vectors
you run into issues of algebraic
independence so much like sort of the
ring lwe we're talking about the
additive lattice loses information about
the multiplicative structure of the
ideal that we have so like that are
linearly independent as vectors but they
their coefficients are algebraically
dependent
Hiram's are totally heuristic so no
totally generic solution is possible you
can write down
multivariate polynomials that just have
infinite numbers of solutions but in
many of the crypto cryptanalytic cases
that we care about there should be like
a you know unique set of solutions and
so you hope to be able to find them the
results are essentially totally ad hoc
so people have tried to give useful
characterizations for when multivariate
coppersmith works and none of them seem
that satisfying they're all very ugly
I'm sorry so I want to mention a brief
sort of application of this to the
approximate common divisor problem so we
already saw ring lwe so you can think of
the approximate common divisor problem
as one-dimensional ring L to be V over
the ring of integers so your input is
this collection of integers which are
multiples of some secret integer P so
that's going to be like the generator of
our of our secret and then plus some
small errors are so you get a bunch of
these and the problem is to find P or
equivalently to find
but if you got the Q eyes then you're
done yeah it's clear the algorithms for
approximate GCD are much more powerful
yeah oh you have to yep you have to you
have to hide a lot more information to I
guess it's equivalent so you can try to
put this into the same kind of framework
if you want so you can like write down a
series of like linear equations have
solutions that are small that would all
vanish like mod some lattice of
polynomial combinations you find a bunch
of short multivariate polynomials in
this lattice and you find the common
roots so that's like the general
framework this works for some parameters
but it feels for small peak and the
reason it fails is due to the
approximation factor of lattice
reduction so this magic thing where the
coppersmith and how grave gram results
were totally rigorous and and didn't
have any problems with the exponential
approximation factor of lol in one
variable
suddenly it does have a problem with the
approximation factor of lol in multiple
this is your paper sure ten years ago
lots of things happening I mean my paper
about this is like also though I barely
remember it so you can try to do the
same thing with ring lwe if you want
this results in like gigantic
dimensional lattices really because you
have like canonical embedding x' that
you're putting in like powers of your
canonical embedding x'
so it seems like kind of nonsensical
maybe there's something better that you
can do that like doesn't require it's
like kind of tempting to want to say
like maybe some of the the clever ideas
from like coppersmith land you kind of
get a quadratic hit in the approximation
factor because like your dimension is
like it doesn't seem to like give you
much improvement unless you can like to
find some better way to deal with the
canonical idea
like five minutes left okay so the last
the last thing I want to mention for for
technique-wise
is a hidden number problem so the hidden
number problem we have some secret
integer alpha and we have a public
parameter there modulus n some integer
and we get multiples so you'd like it's
an Oracle problem you get you hit a
button the Oracle chooses a random
integer TI and then computes TI alpha
mod n and then hands you the most
significant bits of TI outflow reduced
mod n so you get a bunch of pairs TI so
you can formulate this in like kind of
the same framework as we were thinking
before as a system of equations since
one known so we have unknowns are one
through RM and alpha and so we have a
system of linear equations again so
there's unknowns are and unknowns alpha
this is a lot like the stuff that we've
seen before right we have a general size
alpha and small our eyes and so they
hope is to like be able to solve the
system and you can do this so there's a
couple of techniques maybe I'll jump
over this is it should be clear that you
can basically like do the same thing as
you were doing before by putting in
or you can take the dual the usual
approach is actually like the dual of
this lattice so here the original paper
did it as a CBP problem so you have your
target is like your value the distance
between this and some lattice vector mod
n will be
alpha times this vector mod n this is
this will be R and it should be close to
you
you can embed this if if you don't like
solving CBP which nobody in practice
like solving CBP you can just increase
the division every lattice by a couple
of I like to and
so basically you can like do you can
like write down the determinant and like
and so you expect to find this vector
when your pounds this it only works for
random lattices and this is the original
blending of ik Hedison result
essentially said that the limiting
behavior because these are random values
and because you're using lattices
this works for likes for up to login
samples and you have to reveal square
root of login question that I have that
I have not been able to figure out is if
you start this formulation you're like
this looks just like all the other
coppersmith type things that we saw like
why can't you just like do more
multiplicities and get a better result
and it doesn't seem to work I can't
figure out why and it feels really
so all that sort of coppersmith type
tricks that I know about doesn't seem to
actually improve the result or random
instances with some probability benefit
but it's experimental you work um you
need let's see it is so here you
actually need to solve
CBP so you need the the length of the
vector that you're finding to be like in
like shorter than even even if you're
solving CVP you need there not to be any
shorter lattice vectors so in this case
you can you can end up with problems if
you have lattice vectors that are
smaller than your solution random
instances you hope that your lattice
vectors are not smaller than yourself so
I don't think anybody has done any super
sophisticated analysis with this since
like 1996 so if you want to like help
analyze it more carefully then there
might be something
so the application that everybody does
in practice is breaking ECDSA so ICI
Dacia the the important thing is that
you have your signature depends on the
secret not the how to your message so
your secret key and a public part of
your signature and this is a linear
equation and so if you write out if you
get a bunch of DSA or ECDSA signatures
you get a sequence of linear equations
that map's exactly into and so if
somebody screws up and generating there
or they reveal some of the most commute
payment so their signature nonces then
we are exactly in this framework so
people use this all the time in practice
first eye channel basically okay second
at last slide so there's also a Fourier
analysis algorithm for hits the hidden
number problem but it requires many more
samples than the lattice one and it's
kind of a pain so it seems like there
should be some kind of like smooth
trade-off or some relationship between
these algorithms and I don't know of any
but else and also the second application
is the second open problem that I have
is a little bit more applied so the
original bone name think Edison
application was to prove that the most
significant bits of the diffie-hellman
key exchange is our hard core as far as
I know nobody's ever actually found a
realistic scenario where the supplies in
the wild so it would be super cool so
right now everybody uses this to exploit
DSA and ECDSA in the wild but nobody has
ever found a vulnerability that like
gives you the most benefits of a
diffie-hellman zero and if somebody did
find such a vulnerability then you'd be
able to apply the hidden never problem
to be screwed
- hardcore it means that if you can
learn those bits then you can learn the
entire value so learning so those bits
are as hard as learning the entire
secret the principle here is that the
hidden number problem if you get like
some of the most significant bits of
something that is derived from your
secret then you can compute the secret
okay so generally summary there is a
bunch of different lattice constructions
for cryptanalysis I tried to put them
all in a somewhat consistent framework
but there's kind of this general open
problem which is like the theme that I
had which is a lot of these applications
feel like a black art right so like you
think really hard are you to like try
applying things and people write papers
over decades like making small
improvements to these things like why
can't we just systematically like
characterize everything instead of
having to do manual calculation for
every single application it was kind of
painful there's like no general theory
like when does the approximation factor
matter and when doesn't it
when is the coefficient embedding better
than like about the evaluation embedding
sometimes it makes a difference in
practice and sometimes it doesn't
when do amplification techniques like
multiplicity and degree work and when do
they not which polynomials in your ideal
do you include in your lattice basis all
of these things are sort of like
annoyingly
[Applause]
take a break